2° c'était la météo avec sirius
fabricant de chauffe eau solaires à la
réunion c'est l'heure du lundi politique
avec david lorion le début tlr et puis
gueye le dantec bonjour gaël
bonjour j'ai dit bonjour à tous l lundi
politique
gaël le dantec voilà bientôt deux ans
que notre invité fait l'aller retour
entre paris et la réunion entre
l'assemblée nationale et saint-pierre
assidus et actifs sur mon prince et
communiqué de presse régulier
l'université alger aura des fonds ses
idées sa circonscription mais doit aussi
composer avec la politique politicienne
qui les positionne en soutien la ligne
très droitière de laurent wauquiez au
niveau national et localement dans le
camp évidemment de michel fontaine
plutôt que dans celui de didier robert
quel regard porte-t-il aujourd'hui sur
la politique des années le maroc et
l'europe sont ils pour la réunion quelle
mesure pour répondre à la crise sociale
quel avenir pour la droite les voilà
quelques-unes des questions pour être
invité david lorion député républicain
qu'on s'immisce fall saint-pierre éviter
de vie politique sur la première jusqu'à
13h vos questions à partir de 12h45 au
0262 96 2009 bonjour bonjour à tous
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans l'actualité d'abord il ya la
disparition de deux personnalités
réunies ce week-end l'homme politique
marc andré hoarau et de la drass emploi
et puis michel à choix de vos collègues
à l'université vous avez tenir comme
tout à fait michel latchoumanin était le
doyen de la faculté de lettres à
laquelle j'enseigne toujours c'était un
homme extrêmement affable passionné par
la justice sociale passionné par la
réunion passionné par éducation
populaire par l'illettrisme quelqu'un
extrêmement intéressant qui participait
encore à l'actualité politique est
encore très peu de temps avec son livre
notamment sur les gilets jaunes ou alors
ce livre qui s'appelle en finir avec les
inégalités la démo voyoucratie le cri de
révolte de 18 jours
cette crise est ce que vous direz vous
aussi qu'il s'agissait d'un mouvement
qui qui pouvait remettre en question le
système c'est surtout ça fait deux
deux joyaux vous savez à la réunion on
était en train de danser sur un volcan
et il a fini par péter comme on dit on
était vous voulez vous dit ça passe et
données toujours mais on était à au
moment où la crise évidemment à partir
du 17 novembre a commencé et cette crise
elle est révélatrice d'une situation de
fracture sociale qui est une situation
extrêmement tendue avec une société qui
a tendance à la réunion mais aussi en
métropole a su fracturé entre une start
up nation entre des gens qui réussissent
comme si que c'est une obsession social
que de réussir et puis une autre partie
de la population qui s'est senti des
classes et comme disait le président de
la république des gens de rien c'est une
insulte insupportable
évidemment pas entendu l'ensemble de
cette population une fracture
territoriale aussi qui s'est fait encore
beaucoup plus ressentir dans les
outre-mer mais qui est vrai aussi en
métropole donc c'est ce mouvement qui
est un qui vient du fond la france qui
vient ici de la population qui s'est
sentie déclassé qui s'est exprimé à ce
moment là voilà ce qui s'est passé en
réalité tu as vu sourire le président et
le gouvernement a pris la mesure de
cette crise vous qui êtes à paris et
proche du pouvoir parce qu'on y est ce
que vous sentez que quel que la mesure a
été prise moi je j'ai vu surtout de la
part du président beaucoup d'habilité
beaucoup d'habileté politique parce que
en ouvrant le grand débat il a commencé
une sorte de logorrhée politique fin
d'empathie qui a duré plusieurs mois qui
à peine terminée aujourd'hui et on voit
que bout de ce dialogue qui était un
dialogue personnel comme une pièce de
théâtre une sorte de one man show
permanent
il n'y a rien qui se passe il n'y a pas
de proposition qui va naître de ça vous
croyez pas que de ce grand débat va
pouvoir nager quelques provisions non
tout à fait sincèrement je crois que la
france n'a plus les moyens financiers de
mettre sur la table des augmentations
parce qu'elle en a déjà beaucoup fait
parce qu'aujourd'hui les allocations
sont déjà extrêmement importante par
rapport aux bunds revenus du travail et
aussi parce que il ya un sentiment que
la population n'ait pas écouté et
donc il y à des changements à faire et
je crois très certainement qu'il est
peut-être nécessaire de prendre des
mesures fortes et je ne suis pas si
certain que on ne se dirige pas tout
droit vers de nouvelles élections
législatives ou un changement beaucoup
plus profond de gouvernement ou des
référendums ou un changement
constitutionnel
je pense pas la police l'attendait je
pense que l'attenté ne peut y avoir
vraiment un changement de gouvernance
qu'à partir du moment où il ya une
rupture très nette par rapport à la
première moitié du septennat d' emmanuel
macron du quinquennat on va bien le voir
mais on sait bien s'il n'ya pas de
réponse favorable satisfaisante de la
part du gouvernement
le mouvement va naturellement se
réveiller parce qu'à la déception il va
se succéder du mépris et de la haine par
rapport aux élus et par rapport aux
responsables politiques et à ce moment
là on aura plus comme solution viable
que de changer de gouvernement ou de
changer d'élus au parlement et en même
temps vous dit il n'y a pas l'argent
pour continuer à donner plus à ceux que
le plus besoin
je crois que il faut d'abord donner plus
à ceux qui travaillent déjà
parce qu'aujourd'hui entre les revenus
du travail et les revenus des
allocations des revenus sociale les
différences sont tellement faibles que
on ne sait plus dans quelqu'un on se
trouve
vous seriez pour une augmentation du
smic je suis pour simplement que les
allocations sociales soit de 80% du plus
bas revenus de ceux qui travaillent il
faut absolument revaloriser le travail
revaloriser ce qu'ils gagnent
aujourd'hui leur vie qui gagne
difficilement leur vie parce qu'il faut
donner un sens au travail le sens du
travail c'est d'avoir des revenus qui
soient satisfaisants avec lesquels on
peut vivre localement annick girardin
est venue il ya quelques jours
maintenant faire le point sur l'avancée
des propositions lors de sa venue
consacrer
gilet jaune ici qu'est ce que vous
retenez vous deux des trois mots vous
allez je vais très simple communication
communication des communications on a
commencé et que de la com
on a commencé en fait ce mandat
présidentiel par appelle les grandes
assises ou l'outre-mer qui étaient ses
traditionnels puisqu'elle avait déjà
fait en 2007
ça a duré plus d'un an ça a permis
d'écrire un livre bleu dans lesquels
dans lequel on retrouve évidemment tout
ce qu'on savait déjà
on a continué ces discussions par le
grand débat ensuite on a mis en place la
grande conférence du logement dont on
dit que ça va se terminer en juin mais
je ne vois strictement aucune avancée et
puis on repart la ministre intervient
sur une autre stratégie que l'appel la
stratégie 5.0 avec des orientations un
peu utopique mais pendant tout ce temps
là aucune décision réel au contraire
qu'une politique de rabot on nous a
enlevé à chaque fois que ce soit pour
les emplois aidés
il faut savoir quand même qu'il y avait
24 mille emplois aidés aujourd'hui il
reste 11 et 1500 pec la différence de
cette différence est passé au rsa on
nous a enlevé notamment l'accession
sociale qui était une avancée sociale
extrêmement importante pour l accession
sociale à la propriété qui permettait
aux familles agenaises devenir
propriétaire est de faire en sorte que
les enfants deviennent propriétaires ça
a été supprimé c'est qu'un feu de paille
en fait tout l'ensemble des dossiers
2007 comme disait eric l'antenne
aucun dossier aujourd'hui une avancée et
je ne vois dans les discussions qui sont
en cours
aucun projet de mise en place d'une
nouvelle d'un nouveau mode d'accession
sociale
en réalité la politique n'a consisté
qu'à passer des coups de rabot sur la
tva npr sur la l'abattement fiscal
enfin tout ce qui a été fait en fait
depuis le début du mandat ça a été de
raboter les réunionnais localement
didier robert en tant que président de
région centre de production pour
répondre aussi à cette crise
voir charges et les taxes sur les
carburants
et ils lancent ils espèrent pouvoir agir
sur ce pouvoir d'achat en proposant une
continuité territoriale des biens et
marchandises en filmant en finançant le
fait de certaines marchandises c'est
encore un peu un peu fou pour l'instant
ce qui brille et résonne région propose
mais je crois que les acteurs
économiques lui a répondu c'est une
mauvaise idée
c'est une mauvaise idée parce que ça ne
va profiter évidemment qu'aux grands
acteurs du commerce
si vous subventionnez toute la
logistique d'approcher des produits vous
ne posez pas et vous ne pouvez pas
imposer aux acteurs du commerce de
baisser les prix
au contraire vous les enrichit c est
donc ce n'est pas non plus avec 40
millions d'euros
la logistique pour les produits importés
coûte beaucoup plus que ça ce sont aux
commerçants de le payer
ce n'est pas aux réunionnais de payer
cette logistique d' approche
je ne suis pas le seul je crois que
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques le
lui ont dit qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
alors pour améliorer le pouvoir d'achat
pour lutter contre cette vie chère la
raison c'est qu'il
ce qu'il faut c'est évidemment favorisé
et l'envoyé du gouvernement l'a dit mais
je pense que la région le dis aussi
favoriser tout ce qui est concurrence
bien évidemment la concurrence fait
baisser les prix et on sait bien que le
sujet qui est le serpent de mer de la
politique économique c'est l'octroi de
mer e
la région va sûrement travailler sur les
taux d'octroi de mer et qu'il faut
remettre tout à plat en modifiant mais
je crois aussi hélas la ministre a
raison la région a raison il faut
remettre tout à plat l'octroi de mer
autant vous êtes un défenseur mais bien
sûr que je suis l'un défenseur l'octroi
de mer mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
est nécessaire de refaire une fusion de
l'octroi de mer la tva la manière
refaire une seule taxe avec une taxe qui
est une tva tva nationales et une tva
locale
cette tva locale reprenant évidemment
les attributs de l'octroi de mer avec
une somme qui serait versée aux
collectivités
parce qu'il faut évidemment qu'elle
récupère ce qu'elle perde évidemment de
l'octroi de mer et une somme aux
entreprises pour aider les ans
reprise à pratiquer des prix notamment
d'une production que ce soit la
production locale ou à l'exportation qui
soit capable de faire face à la
concurrence de l'importation
l'octroi de mer aujourd'hui un défaut
c'est celui de la difficulté à voir
combien on paie exactement parce que la
tva repose sur un prix caf plus l'octroi
de mer et donc on ne peut pas le
calculer est donc les réunionnais qui ne
peuvent pas le calcul et pense très
souvent que c'est l'ex trois maires qui
grèvent le prix des produits
c'est pas toujours frais et c'est ce que
j'ai descendu très souvent c'est souvent
la marche évidemment des produits qui
grèvent le prix l'octroi noir il faut le
défendre
lorsqu il s'attache aux morts
différentiel de taux sur l'ensemble de
ses produits
mais il faut trouver des solutions je
suis après prêts à travailler tout le
monde
la région avec l'état avec tous les
spécialistes évidemment pour mettre en
place mais ça se met en deux trois ans
une nouvelle visibilité de cette taxe de
l'octroi de mer pour en même temps
permettre d'appuyer un impôt sur
peut-être une base plus large et
maintenir des différentiels de taux pour
protéger notre production locale
mais c'est un chantier 2 3 ans qu'il
faut commencer dès maintenant pour
donner une visibilité sur les prix à la
réunion
un mot sur l'emploi là pour vous irez
vos positions de la région autour des
aides aux entreprises avec les résultats
à vue ce n'est pas forcément évident
mesurer là encore et et plus de pecs
plus de d'emplois aidés est ce que ces
deux levier sur les bras à chênée
d'affaires
les contrats aidés sont nécessaires à la
région il en faut plus parce que lorsque
vous avez 42% de la population qui sont
en dessous du seuil de la pauvreté
et je le dis aux réunionnais le seuil de
la pauvreté à la réunion était de 570
euros le seuil de la pauvreté en
métropole et 2015 euros est donc déjà en
nous pénalise à 1015 rôle beaucoup plus
il y aurait encore à 100 plus importants
évidemment de populations pauvres et on
ne peut pas tout de suite dire toute
cette population formée vous sans savoir
exactement où est ce qu'elle va dans
quelle entreprise elle va travailler
donc qu'il faut modifier les contrats
aidés lui donner plus de substance et
j'ai déjà fait la proposition en dix ans
mettons en place des contrats aidés
mais avant d'avoir un contre
aider avec un an de formation de manière
à ce qu'on fait une synthèse de la
formation et des contrats aidés pour
permettre une mise en emploi des
réunionnais qui soit beaucoup plus
intelligente que le seul contrat aidé ou
la seule formation aujourd'hui
acceptable d'avoir une formation
qualifiante et m alors l'emploi et 17
870 euros et il faut que l'état
investisse beaucoup plus en même temps
sur la formation en même temps sur
l'accompagnement parce qu'il faut bien
que les gens puissent vivre lorsque vous
faites une formation vous devez pouvoir
vivre en même temps et vous ne ferez pas
de formation s'ils ne vous pouvez pas
vivre
donc il faut à l'investissement de
l'état dans les contrats aidés et dans
la formation l'état l'a fait dans la
formation
bien que tous les décrets ne soit pas
encore signé l'état n'a pas fait dans
les contrats aidés
en ce qui concerne la région et les
entreprises la région a mis en place des
subventions qui sont intéressantes des
subventions qui accompagne les
entreprises le seul reproche que je peux
lui faire et j'étais à la région pendant
sept ans avec l'équipe de didier robert
vous avez des vice présidents c'est de
dire que la région doit être beaucoup
plus une agence stratégique du
développement de la réunion
aujourd'hui il ya une sorte de rôle
partagé entre necsa et la région c'était
pas une bonne chose
la région s'est alors précipitée pour
l'auditeur
c'est une séance m dont la mission est
d'accompagner évidemment la région et
les exportations de la région le
développement économique de la région
mais la région son principal rôle c'est
d'être une agence stratégique de
développement et d'appuyer les
entreprises tant dans la production
locale que dans l'exportation
c'est son rôle principal son rôle n'est
pas être d'être le conseil départemental
ce n'est pas une agence évidemment de
distribution des moyens publics
je ne dis pas que c'est une mauvaise
chose le pop la continuité territoriale
les aides mais il faut avant tout que ça
ça s'organise comme dans une agence
stratégique de développement et il faut
qu'on voit dans quelles sont les
orientations que la région prend alors
je ne dis pas qu'à n'a pas il y en a
dans l'économie maritime ça vient de se
mettre en place dans l'environnement et
à des choses qui sont faites en matière
d'agro alimentaire l'agriculture par
exemple et des choses ces filières doit
être beaucoup plus visible et la région
ce projet sera le pivot pour venir
rapidement sur le mouvement des gilets
jaunes et un autre aspect de ce qui a
été
ce qui va ressortir de revendication
c'est la crise et de voir si telle
qu'elle fonctionne actuellement
vous avez été très critique vous les
élus en général
comment est ce que vous avez vécu on est
dans les solutions comme le conseil
consultatif par exemple est ce que c est
que c'est la bonne voie dans une des
revendications très simple délit j'étais
jeune il y avait plus de démocratie
participative
c'est clair les gens veulent parce
qu'ils connaissent l'actualité il
regarde sur les réseaux sociaux
participer davantage être consultés il
ya une formule qui vous semblent
convenir sans en parler du riq du rip du
voile à deux référendums d'initiative
populaire
historienne de conseil consultatif
citoyen quelle est la forme qui vous
plaît lorsqu'on est en démocratie
représentative
quelques ondées aujourd'hui je crois
qu'il faut bien mettre en évidence que
les élus doivent représenter la
population et leur rendre des comptes à
rendre des comptes ça veut dire que
chaque élu doit être soumis peut-être à
mi mandat
un bilan une évaluation du travail qu'il
a pu faire le travail parlementaire mais
du travail aussi dans une collectivité
et doit rendre des comptes tout à fait
ici officiellement et d'autre est évalué
sur son travail
je pense que avant de tout changer sur
le plan de la constitution on peut très
vite mettre en place un bilan
d'évaluation de chacun des élus en
disant qu'elle et lui a fait quoi
quel est son travail est ce qu'ils
méritent évidemment de continuer et est
ce que dans la deuxième partie de son
mandat par exemple et ne peut il peut se
rattraper ou faire mieux que ce qu'il a
fait et s'il a fait évidemment une
première moitié de mandat moins bien
voilà une chose assez simple à mettre en
place une évaluation à mi mandat
après pour tout ce qui concerne un
changement constitutionnel par exemple
la mise en place d'un référendum
d'initiative citoyens citoyennes
ça existe un certain pays la france est
un pays avec évidemment plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'habitants
ce n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
que la suisse il faut je crois le
prévoir dans un changement
constitutionnel et peut-être mettre en
place les outils informatiques qui
permettrait et je suis favorable sur
certains sujets d'avoir une consultation
directe la population en tout cas je ne
suis pas défavorable
david rire vous êtes chargé d'un rapport
parlementaire sur la réforme des congés
bonifiés
pourquoi faut-il réformer c'était de
fonctionnaires ultramarins ça contre
auxerre ce n'est pas moi qui souhaitent
le réformer en fait il faut bien dire
comment les choses se sont passées c'est
une indiscrétion levé par un syndicat
souvent les syndicats font un travail
formidable dans ce domaine ce sont des
lanceurs d'alert qui a surpris en fait
d'un coup dans un compte-rendu
interministériel le fait que le
gouvernement voulait complètement
réformer les congés bonifiés et à partir
de là ces syndicats nous ont alertés
dans le cas de la délégation autres
maires pour nous dire faites attention
le gouvernement veut réformer dans le
sens de le réduire tellement à peu de
chose qu'il aurait en fait disparu les
congés bonifiés
mais je voudrais vous dire une chose et
congés bonifiés c'est ce qui existe en
même temps que la création des
départements d'outre-mer
avant ça s'appelait les congés
administratifs et puis après deux
minutes 1977 des crédits 917 c'est
devenu les congés bonifiés
quand j'ai bonifié c'est un enjeu humain
c'est un lien familial qu'un
fonctionnaires ultramarins qui part avec
le baby d'hommes à partir de 1963
aujourd'hui avec la dom qui part en tant
que policier qui tarde en tant
qu'infirmier en métropole avec des
salaires qui sont de 1200 1300 euros
souhaite garder avec la famille qui se
trouve à lannion et je peux vous dire
que j'en ai rencontré des policiers qui
ne peuvent pas imaginer payer un voyage
à toute la famille s'il n'y avait pas de
congés bonifiés et donc ça aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui fait vivre
trente cinq mille fonctionnaires c'est
d'avoir cet avantage à ce qu'on leur a
demandé à un moment donné d'aller
pouvoir travailler en métropole et ils
se disent eh ben on va pouvoir rentrer
tous les trois ans avec l'aide de l'état
pour passer un peu de temps avec notre
famille c'est de ça qu'il s'agissait
d'un enjeu humain avant tout la
confusion de votre rapport on peut
l'imaginer il faut bien on sait pas il
faut toucher rien il y a quelques
difficultés parce que les congés
bonifiés dans leur longueur aujourd'hui
c'est 65 jours c'est peut-être trop long
et peut-être le cd faut peut être
regarder la volonté des uns et des
autres de partir peut-être plus souvent
mais en tout cas il ne faut pas le
casser il ne faut pas enlever ce qui
reste de rêve et de possibilité de
maintenir un lien familial aux
fonctionnaires ultramarins oltramare un
qui travaille aujourd'hui en métropole
est dans l'actualité david aurait aussi
cette grogne qui monte en ce moment
contre la loi bancaire les formes de
l'éducation nationale loi sur l'école de
la confiance
ça s'appelle vous avez voté vous êtes
joie vous comprenez aujourd'hui des
inquiétudes des enseignants des parents
par rapport à par rapport à ce projet ce
soit au niveau du lycée avec des options
pour être distribué partout au niveau de
l'école avec de l'argent qui pourrait
partir dans ces mots privé parce que
complications de lancer dès 3 ans du
coup la finance et le privé avec des
rapprochements entre les écoles et les
collèges dans toute loi vous pouvez
trouver évidemment du positif et du
négatif
j'ai voté cette loi d'ailleurs je suis
le seul de mon groupe politique l'avoir
boudé sais que j'ai fait une démarche
donc très politique
j'ai voté cette loi parce que on voit
trop souvent surtout en métropole mais
quelquefois à la réunion des jeunes
enfants de 3 à 6 ans qui ne sont pas
scolarisés
alors je ne dis pas que tout cela la
rigueur il ya des trappeurs et notre peu
mais il en existe mais surtout dans les
rues notamment à paris des enfants entre
3 et 6 ans qui font la manche et ont
quelque part l'école c'est la
possibilité d'interdire sa d'interdire
ce que les enfants déjà avant 6 ans de
soi dans la rue est-ce que vous pourrez
vous battre pour ce soit appliquée à
mayotte si l'ours à mayotte
il a été créé notamment lors de cette
loi sur l'école le rectorat mayotte
c'est aussi pour ça notamment avec mon
collègue donso kamardine que j'ai voté
et lorsqu'il m'a demandé de voter cette
loi il y a eu évidemment un certain
nombre de discussions
je crois que il faut encore que cette
loi puisse être améliorée notamment au
sénat puisqu'il est en deuxième lecture
au sénat avec
le lien qui doit être fait entre l'école
primaire le collège sans que évidemment
les directeurs d'école de perdre leur
pouvoir mais il est évident qu'il est
possible et que cela doit être fait un
lien plus fort entre l'école primaire et
le collège avec chacun dans ses
prérogatives
alors évidemment la tendance du
gouvernement c'est d'essayer de faire
des économies partout mais je crois
qu'il faut justement essayer de faire en
sorte que cette loi ne soit pas la loi
encore une loi d'économies et que on
donne la possibilité évidemment d'être
dans une loi de de politiques publiques
qui soit une grande loi
il reste encore des réformes à faire
mais je crois qu'elle va dans le bon
sens à saint pierre vous avez été
confronté vous c'est toujours spécial
ça a des bureaux manifestation
d'enseignants de parents sont confrontés
devant la diminution de la scène qui
résulte de la diminution du nombre de
contrats aidés
quelle est la solution aujourd'hui pour
une commune comme saint pierre est ce
qu'il faut intégrer plus fort mais plus
pour que les petits écoliers de ce1 bien
une conditions d'études que ce métropole
ils les ont la vie devant la scène
parfois le nombre d'affamés conforme au
moyen d'une honda somme qu'on trouve
évidemment en région métropolitaine on
avait en fait à la réunion plus d'assen
en réalité par classe il y serait mieux
évidemment qu'il y ait plus d'un cem par
classe ça permettrait un encadrement un
accompagnement des enseignants qu'ils
soient de meilleure qualité
je crois qu'il est nécessaire de l'avoir
condition que les collectivités et des
moyens aujourd'hui les collectivités
jouent un rôle qui est un rôle disons
d'état providence pour l'état par
rapport à la population
lorsque vous à une population aussi pop
il faut évidemment la compagnie dans le
cadre du ccs dans le cas des contrats
aidés les nouveaux pec dont vous citez
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus 80%
l'accompagnent dans l'état c'est 50%
d'accompagnement de l'état
elles dorment dans ce quart est ce que
c'est les collectivités cadres et house
et des taquets les collectivités quand
vous êtes à 50 50
et donc on donne aux collectivités ce
rôle d'accompagnement social
d'amortisseur social et on ne peut pas
tout faire parce que les recettes
fiscales à la réunion forcément elles
sont moindres qu'en métropole
donc il faut qu'à un moment donné le
gouvernement regarde les outre-mer avec
d'autres yeux que ceux de bercy avec
insu c'est pas gagné
non c'est pas gagné et c'est pour ça que
je suis parfois très en colère avec la
ministre
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la
ministre de l'outre-mer qui gère l'autre
mère c'est bercy qui se sert du rabot
lurabo budgétaire pour gérer les
outre-mer c'est ce qu'on vit en fait
dans les collectivités aujourd'hui et
c'est sur quoi il faut se battre
le gouvernement a procédé à un
remaniement ministériel ya sa part de
plusieurs miroirs des scrutins
municipaux ils se marient en ramenant
ainsi matagne acquis qui part du cabinet
de la présidente alizés comme
porte-parole du gouvernement
c'est rico qui était lui aussi pensait y
avait dix équivalentes à celles liées au
numérique et amélie dauphin qui était
aussi une très proche de ce qu'elles
font très impressionnant qui par
l'impression que leur réserve de
remplaçants un peu limité et qui va
piocher dans ses très proches depuis
aujourd'hui c'est un changement
technique un gouvernementale a mais ils
m'ont chalain travaillais déjà avec le
président de manière très très proches
je la connais bien puisque elle et elle
est à l'assemblée nationale c'est la
vice-présidente du groupe de dallaire
web
c'est une personnalité brillante 1 sur
le plan budgétaire
aujourd'hui elle quitte le parlement
pour aller en tant que ministre en tant
que secrétaire d'état chargé des
affaires européennes
là c'est une suite logique après le
départ de madame loiseau les deux autres
remplaçants sont des gens qui étaient
déjà avec le président et qui changent
simplement de nom il passe de conseiller
à secrétaire d'état en réalité n'y a pas
de changement dans ce gouvernement
je pense que le vrai changement il va se
faire après les européennes
en fonction du résultat évidemment des
européennes et là on va savoir si c'est
comme je vous ai dit lorsque si c'est
une nouvelle élection législative c'est
un changement radical de gouvernement
avec un changement de prévenir
personnellement je m'attends à une
réforme très importante
ces élections européennes qui approche
ces importantes pour la réunion parce
que la politique européenne a des
conséquences évidemment ici quelques l
europe vous vous défendre vous
souhaiteriez défendre quand on vois je
vais préciser maxence aux citadins
d'autres partis lancent en ce qui
concerne par exemple la présentation des
candidats la réplique à ma fille n'est
question que de ses candidats qui
voudraient plus d'immigrés je vous avoue
qu'au centre votre site internet est
aujourd'hui la liste les républicains et
soutenues par les républicains mais
aussi évidemment par d'autres formations
qui sont des formations centristes
par exemple valérie pécresse qui est
venu le temps du bilan c'est une
républicaine party les républicains
évidemment soutient cette liste vous
avez le partage centriste young du goût
doit à sa représentante agnès evren qui
évidemment sur la liste de numéro deux
hervé morin qui est le représentant du
parti et les centristes qui soutient
cette liste et moi je soutiens
évidemment cette liste si on compare pas
avec morin mais je soutiens évidemment
cette descente en république si vous
citez moi ça veut dire que vous situer
plutôt dans cette mouvance à moi je
trouve plutôt surtout que sur le niveau
requis oui je me situe plutôt dans ce
qu'on appelle le mouvement des
gaullistes sociaux menés notamment par
daniel fasquelle qui est une digne qui
fait partie évidemment on est
républicain mais avec un certain nombre
d'orientations qui sont des orientations
beaucoup plus social que que la ligne en
fait wauquiez qui n'est pas la seule qui
représente évidemment dans cette liste
les républicains qu'est ce que la
d'original cette liste c'est simplement
parce que on a en fait deux autres
listes qui sont en face effectivement
une liste du rassemblement national qui
prône ce qu'on appelle une europe des
nations où on se renferme chaque pays
les uns et les autres en ne construisant
plus l'europe c'est parce que je veux et
puis à la liste de des maillols mettront
en marche et qui s'appelle renaissance
je crois et qui prône une europe avec
plus de pays encore avec encore plus
d'ouverture
avec une europe encore plus diluées qui
va finir nécessairement par faire en
sorte que chacun des pays européens ne
se sent plus à l'aise dans l'europe et
qui va engendrer un certain nombre de
problèmes tels que le bric si par
exemple moi je prône une europe qui soit
une transformation de cette europe une
europe des projets parce qu'il faut
faire des projets en europe
il faut un moment donné qu'on pense que
l'europe nous servent et qu'est-ce
qu'elle quoi ça peut nous servir par
exemple faire une recherche européenne
sur les malades d'alzheimer à faire une
europe de la jeunesse avec un erasmus
européen il faut une europe des projets
il faut une europe puissante parce qu'on
n'a pas le choix aujourd'hui face à la
chine face aux états unis que d'avoir un
continent puissant parce que sinon on va
se faire envahir en fait par les chinois
et par la technologie chinois et je le
dis souvent à mon groupe
ce n'est pas les quelques syriens aient
les quelques érythréens qui viennent
aujourd'hui en europe qui le vrai danger
c'est la technologie la finance chinoise
qui va nous envoyer votre sang n'ont pas
l'impression que vous soyez entendu mais
si vous regardez bien ce qui est dans le
programme de cette liste et républicains
vous voyez que l'europe puissance
notamment mais aussi l'europe de la
civilisation l'europe des valeurs
l'europe on conserve notre patrimoine
puisque dans le projet des républicains
il ya 1 % du budget européen qui doit
aller vers la le maintien du patrimoine
notamment alors que c'est 0,15
aujourd'hui seulement est donc une
certain nombre d'orientations dans cette
liste
dans cette liste qui me qui me fait
penser que l'europe doit être
transformée et ne se sont pas les deux
autres listes celle dans marche est
celle du rassemblement national qui peut
le faire est ce qu'il y aura un
réunionnais sur cette liste il y aura un
ultramarin la 20e position
comme c'est le cas d'ailleurs un de
maurice ponga qui était la 20e position
sur la liste de républicains lors de la
dernière élection et publie donc pas de
réguler
je ne suis pas encore là la place n'est
pas encore déterminé à vous aurez
intéressez-vous si on est tous n'étaient
pas déjà un peu créé ce qui m'a beaucoup
fait rêver aujourd'hui ce sont des
projets
régionaux et projets locaux des projets
d'aménagement du territoire c'était mon
domaine de prédilection
j'adore évidemment ce que je fais
aujourd'hui le domaine législatif est un
domaine que j'apprends à connaître sur
lesquels il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire notamment parce qu'il ya une
réelle adaptation notamment de notre
politique ultra marines mais forcément
l'europe aujourd'hui même si les
réunionnais s'intéresse trop peu
seulement 13 % de votes c'est trop peu
d'accord est indispensable et il nous
faut un continent européen fort il faut
que dans ce continent européen
notamment les outre mer soit la classe
politique est ce que vous savez
à l'heure où on n'est pas sur les
doubles mandats je ferai d'abord à deux
députés à l'assemblée nationale et je
n'ai pas aujourd'hui un instant penser à
être député européen et est ce que l
inverse un retour à une politique plus
réaliste vous parler ou les élections et
chance à venir sans doute bien sûr
précisément on pourrait vous voir aux
municipales aux régionales vous savez
aujourd'hui c'est c'est le premier c'est
le 1er avril
et je vais vous faire une citation si
vous voulez d'alexandra 1000 dhs c'est
winnie l'ourson ou inédits quelle
journée et porcines et 10 c c'est
aujourd'hui et winnie dit c'est le
meilleur des jours d'accord à première
vue on ne rien dire mais on aurait pu
vous savez en vie aujourd'hui je suis
député je travaille en tant que député
c'est un travail passionnant pragmatique
réaliste qu'il faut faire on à emmanuel
qui nous appellent de saint-pierre
qu'une question pour vous écouter annuel
oui bonjour bonjour bonjour et lorient
bonjour être une question fait en fait
quand c'est juste contredire un prix
cible de travail chez palm montait à la
barre franchement votre intervention lue
et les pros classe bon disons qu on
raconte notre opinion sur le terrain de
nice en fait que me regarde fixement
devant dont notamment côtés des députés
des trucs il fait le buzz
ap toute l'année ce qui l'émeut bike ou
qu'il fait chez guignols que coach avait
bien vous ne voyez pas où j'ai enfin que
l'on devrait être diffusé en fait ce
pourquoi ils ont été réunis clannad
existe aussi pour y arriver nous sommes
nous pas nous rendre à grenade one a
mieux commencé que tant de son école
mais que ça rit la balle tout dupe on
est bien avec la veille tconférence le
bonne franchise rebonds je suis sans
voix contre et vos panneaux qui ne
souhaitent pas ils ont mis trois ans à
le porter automatique mais sans parler
en détail très bien collaboré unis merci
mais c'est bien de défendre plan il faut
être fier de la langue créole
il faut être fier de la réunion et il
faut aller en disant que lé pas plus nou
lé pa moin nul est capable comme toute
demande de défendre
évidemment la réunion ça c'est quelque
chose d'important pour moi comme
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres députés un
même des députés de gauche
kiala qui a au parlement défend
évidemment ligne david orientale
d'ailleurs vous avez dans les bois
éducation ce qu'il y ait une place plus
importante pour l'histoire des autres
vous avez été partiellement entendus oui
on avait déposé un certain nombre
d'amendements pour que les outre mer
soit identifiée comme une partie du
territoire français
moi j'ai déposé un amendement qui a été
adoptée notamment sur la cartographie en
disant que dans tous les livres dont
toutes les cartes dans toutes les cartes
officielles
lorsqu'on dessine la cartographie de la
france doit être présent sur cette carte
l'ensemble des outre mer d'autres
députés et donc j'ai signé les
amendements ont déposé des amendements
sur la langue créole la langue créole
n'est pas une obligation mais si on veut
faire société à la réunion il faut qu'on
dise que la langue créole peut être
apprises peut être enseignée peut-être
parler l'histoire et la jouerie de la
majorité parlementaire nous a tiré
dessus
non mais c'est dommage mais c'est pas
pour ça que je la défendrai pas
l'histoire de la réunion est une
histoire mondiale
l'histoire les sauvages évidemment
l'histoire de la réunion entend collini
l'histoire de la réunion en tant que
département c'est une histoire mondiale
il faut qu'elle soit intégré à
l'histoire française david loriot chaque
partie on le voit en ce moment en france
2 se verdir nombreuses autres écologique
de l'écossé programme dense et lis aussi
vous êtes jeunes vous êtes sensibilisé
parfois chargé des questions liées au
climat et aux questions d'aménagement du
territoire qu'il faut avec ces questions
climatiques d'évolution du casque vous
vous êtes inquiet oui je suis inquiet
parce que nous sommes en train de
détruire notre planète et nous sommes en
train de dérégler notre climat et je le
dis avec beaucoup de force
mais je suis d'autant plus inquiet que
quelquefois je vois des déclarations
complètement utopique
face à cela lorsque on est responsable
on doit déjà être réaliste pragmatique
sérieux parce que vous pensez à quoi je
pense je prends simplement à un dossier
et qui aujourd'hui fait l'actualité au
traitement des déchets j'allais venir
eh bien vous avez raison simplement
parce que aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
cinquante solutions pour traiter les
déchets
dans tous les pays que ce soit en europe
du nord sont en europe du sud dans tous
les pays développés
il y à un traitement multi filières des
déchets qui doit être adoptée à la
réunion c'est urgent de le faire on a
déjà trop tardé
le traitement des déchets c'est le tri
ça commence par le tri le tri en même
temps des bacs jaunes en même temps des
bacs verts avec un tri du verre un tri
dû faire un tri des batteries un tri du
papier et que ça ça doit aller
l'ensemble de ces matériaux recyclables
vers des filières du recyclage une fois
que ce tri est fait il y à une deuxième
phase qui est une phase de la
valorisation valorisation des matières
humide avec lequel on fait la
valorisation organique pour faire du
méthane du compost et une dernière phase
de valorisation des valorisations de
matières sèches tout ce qu'on n'a pas pu
évidemment récupérer précédemment avec
lequel on fait des brigades de matière
sèche et qui est valorisé dans une unité
de valorisation énergétique que certains
l'appellent incinérateurs et tant qu'ils
ne veulent pas et je vais vous dire un
mot là-dessus c'est la valorisation à
100 % de ces déchets qui est pratiqué
partout dans tous les pays développés
je crois qu'il y a là une erreur et une
erreur barre mais peut-être parfois par
par les journalistes en europe on
pourrait bien la position que vous
critiquiez c'est celle de la région de
la région qui fait dit non mais qui dit
devant l'assemblée plénière
sa dernière qu'il dit ne pas intégrer
ces uv eux dans le plan de l'énergie
parce que ils contestent leur efficacité
leur utilité je vais vous dire une chose
simple là dessus on emploie le terme
incinérateur parce qu'on a peur
d'expliquer et souvent la peur fait
qu'on va au plus simple
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un incinérateur
sénateurs ça n'existe plus né en europe
1 france a existé incinérateur c'est
lorsque vous prenez tous les chez vous
mettez au four et vous les incinérer
points et ben ça ça n'existe plus ça n'a
pas une banalité de valorisation n'y a
pas à se battre contre un incinérateur
qui n'existe pas ou qui n'existe plus on
des fous il n'y a qu'à l'intérêt de n'y
a pas que la galerie du robert
refuser ces cesu vu qu'ils ne sont pas
aussi neutre qui ne craignent rien
d'autre que je vous dis d'un côté il n'y
a pas d'un côté des gens qui pensent
eric qui réfléchissent et qu'ils font
bien et de l'autre côté des gens
stupides ignares et qui veulent polluer
la population non mais qu'est ce qu'un
direction lundi kent et cesser de nous
éclairer parce que c'est une question
qui revient régulièrement sur les
émissions politiques c'est quoi une
opposition d'hommes d'ego entre une
vraie question
derrière une question d'environnement il
n'y a pas de son credo
il ya simplement le fait que à la
réunion il faut mettre en place un
traitement multi filières de l'ensemble
des déchets il n'y a pas cinquante après
évidemment il ya une question d'hommes
évidemment ce projet multi filières du
pôle sud des déchets a été pensé depuis
une dizaine d'années qui apparaît vers
lé bas et donc soutenu par avec avec
trois pc qui le portent aujourd'hui
c'est pour dire la vérité
243 millions d'euros c'est 700 emplois
directs et indirects et c'est un projet
porté par de l'argent public par une
collectivité publique donc entièrement
maîtrisée et donc aujourd'hui
évidemment si ce projet réussi c'est un
projet qui est important pour le sud est
qui est important pour le développement
la réunion le président de région
apparemment lui un autre projet je
reviens qu'ils nous les voiles mais je
ne pense pas qu'il je pense pas qu'il
faut qu'il soit aussi capricieux j'ai
beaucoup d'amitié pour didier robert on
est du même âge on a fait les mêmes
écoles
on se voit de temps en temps et on a
travaillé ensemble la région mais tout à
fait sincèrement et je vous le dis je
dis à tous les réunionnais le fait de
dire que le csr le combustible solide
récupérables ne peut pas être brûlé dans
une unité de valorisation énergétique
c'est un caprice d'enfant gâté d'accord
puisque en même temps le même présent
deux régions prône la can fibre qui va
entrer dans une unité de valorisation
énergétique la bagasse qui rentre dans
une unité de variations erratiques et de
toute évidence le projet nord va aussi
produire des csr qui va entrer dans une
unité de relations énergétiques
notamment sur bois rouge
je veux dire par là que tout le projet
que l'on porte lui la région comme il
eva et le même projet c'est un projet de
tri c'est un projet de récupération
c'est un projet de valorisation c'est un
projet de valorisation énergétique
c'est le même projet et qui n'est à la
dent que de caprice d'hommes merci david
lorion d'avoir été avec nous évidemment
sur cette politique qui qui va qui dure
des missions de mission et de me revoir
d'élection en élection vous pouvez me
dire vous voulez pas toujours pas de
dire quelle élection vous verra bientôt
vous savez s'il ya une dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale ce sera en tant
que député d'accord merci beaucoup et je
vous remercie avec une envie politique
la première à la plaine des palmistes
89.6
12h15 à 13h le club de la presse sur la
première on va parler des élections
européennes qui sont d'accord sur rien
sauf une chose qu'il faut prendre
il y avait une vraie tentative de
conjonction entre 0 berre et dès qu'on
soit pour ou contre moi je vous dis je
suis ni pour ni contre le club de la
presse tous les mardis de tous